let's jump to the current state of the
union
where are we right now are we entering
hard times i think the answer is yes
then we have some metrics to back that
up
from deadline joe biden's address to
congress snares 26.9 million viewers hey
26.9 million that's what like uh three
times the oscars
that's oh yeah yeah yeah but no no
that's that's what how many people voted
uh so that's 81 million yeah so uh 30
percent of the people
wow so not a whole lot of people but but
26.9 that's surely a good number
way down from trump oh wait wait wait
hold on a minute way
down hold on a minute you mean to tell
me that donald trump got 47.7 million
viewers
in his first speech to a joint session
on february 28th
okay oh okay so so all right all right
you know
it's a it's a little bit more than half
it's not that bad we're still good i'm
sure
of the people who watched you know joe
biden speak
considering they were much less people
right it was probably way more people
who actually liked biden yeah definitely
so so i'm sure
i'm sure the polling is going to be
really good for biden and we can breathe
the cyber relief i actually have a cnn
article seven in ten who watched biden's
speech
said it left them feeling optimistic
okay that's good so uh
all right considering that there was you
know way less people
it makes sense that biden would have
pulled better than donald trump uh they
say
the 51 percent who had a very positive
view
positive reaction abide in speech is a
bit more more muted
than reaction to the first address from
other recent presidents wait a minute
wait wait what
51 that's a good number right yeah what
what what was what was donald trump
surely less than that 57 oh
with more viewers donald trump had more
people with a very positive reaction to
his speech
yeah we're not doing too well even the
people who voted for by don't care about
biden
no they voted against trump that's right
and so you can't function as a society
when you have no cohesion
so now we have we we we had a we have we
have a political
institution built upon hating donald
trump who's gone
that's it trump he's he's chilling he's
playing golf
so now the people who are like well
trump's gone we're done now it's just a
hollow shell
there's nothing there there's no
substance to the biden administration
right
all i was seeing yesterday the headlines
biden's first 100 days address
to congress oh wow kamala harris the
first woman to sit behind
biden with nancy pelosi that like that's
listen i'm not against like firsts right
for for women for minorities i think
that's cool i think that's awesome but
i think it's awesome when they actually
have done something
and when they've actually accomplished a
lot from the country kamal harris
did accomplish something oh yeah
california she is the first woman
to become vice president after earning
zero delegates
in the democratic party first well
here's the thing you see them all
celebrating kamala harris right you see
all these articles it's all about race
it's all about gender it's all about sex
no substance right no accomplishments no
real accomplishments okay
she did lock up those innocent people to
use a slave labor during the wildfires
yeah but the thing is right now keep
them locked up i'm sorry i'm sorry
everybody fact check she's
she is the border czar apparently right
she she's the one that is supposed to be
overseeing what's taking place with the
border and
i think this is where a lot of
minorities people that don't think about
these things
they get manipulated it's like look at
the first woman to sit behind
a male during a congressional address
it's like well has she done anything
no no she's the first woman yeah yeah
yeah do you like this
continue to see it because that's what
you should care about it's like well we
still have a humanitarian
a strategic humanitarian crisis at the
southern border they're not doing
anything to better it they're actually
facilitating it they're
actually trying to sweep it under the
rug by unofficially gagging
border patrol agents and i can confirm
that because i've talked to them
when you go up and you interview them at
the southern border they literally the
first thing they tell you is
i can't talk to you but uh here's what's
going on you know what i'm trying to say
to him
is we should not be glorifying and
celebrating politicians
just because of their gender their sex
or even the color of their skin
when they're not doing anything to
better the country
kamala harris should not be celebrated
because she's not doing anything
especially with what's going on at the
southern border why didn't they address
it last night
you know what i really love about i mean
that's going on is that
over the past four years it's not just
the political landscape that's been
that's a their whole identity is trump
sucks but the entire
media environment built an audience that
specifically just
hated donald trump you'd think the
border crisis would be
as what did that technical director at
cnn say gangbusters for ratings
he said kovid was you'd think right now
they would be like crisis at the border
but their audience
only cares about trump yeah so what are
they going to report on
if they come out and talk about the
crisis of the border the people who care
about real news left a long time ago
yeah so they can't yeah they don't give
a damn so you have all of these huge
big breaking stories conflict with
ukraine and russia
you've got now the u.s firing at iranian
you know uh
boats they were like military ships a
little little uh not chips boats
and now you've got the crisis at the
board which has been ongoing
i mean normally the media loves this
stuff if they leave
leads right they do care the problem is
they make some money and clicks
if you have a hundred million that's all
that's all well imagine this you have
100 million core viewers
and then donald trump gets elected so
you scream about trump all of a sudden
your raiders go up to 110 you're like
whoa
but what you don't realize you actually
lost 10 million core
news fans and gained 20 million
zealots over time your ratings are
improving
but you're actually losing all of the
people who care about news and gaining
zealots
what happens now trump leaves the
zealots leave for the most part
the people who care about news left
years ago people like me i used to have
seen on for the news
cnn on for the news and then they
weren't talking about anything fox news
covering protests in iran turn on cnn
donald trump today i don't care i turned
it off i don't watch it anymore
you if you want to go to news you can't
go to cnn anymore
so now they have to ignore these things
now they have to ignore the border
crisis
it's not just that it's bad for biden
yeah so their whole audience is
anti-trump
some of it pro-biden if they come out
now and say there's a crisis people are
gonna get mad at him
they've lost any credibility they've had
the media is a is a withered
husk of its former self what someone
graffiti trump sucks on
and i don't think anybody's really
interested in standing at the thing
anymore
this is why i just i hope people
listening they they they hear this and
they understand that they're being
used i'm going to preach this until
there's no more lungs in my breath
because minority is a special breath a
normal a breath in my lungs because
i'm very passionate about this because
people need to understand that they are
literally being used as political pawns
like really think about this see through
this why is it just exactly what tim
just explained
why is it just because trump is not in
office they're not talking about the
border anymore
when it's worse than it was under trump
but then these are the same people you
have
you have chris cuomo and uh you have don
lemon and you have
uh brian stelter you have all these
virtue signalers on cnn every single
night saying
oh we care so much about the black
people we care so much about the
minorities but they're not reporting
what's taking place at the southern
border
there are literally migrants right now
by the hundreds by the thousands
that are being stuffed into trucks and
stash houses in the united states by the
cartels
against their will that is that is not
migration that is not immigration that
is human trafficking
by the hour by the minute listen i gotta
say this tim
because cnn won't say it msnbc won't say
it but they'll sit there and they'll
continue to virtue signal like they care
about us
but they don't because if they did just
to go literally to your point
they only do it for clicks and for
ratings and when it's a political attack
against a conservative or donald trump
they won't talk about it because they
don't care
and i need people to understand they
don't listen minorities tim you know
this
minorities believe that these people
care about them well they don't care
about us overwhelmingly voting for
democrats
yes year after year after year after
year after year
the past election seeing a lot of
latinos vote republican not that i like
the republican party but just getting
with the democrats at least
is it gives you some optimism and then
just thinking about the media
kind of failing and and fumbling and joe
biden's ratings collapsing
actually i'm kind of feeling pretty good
about that we
you know we're we're on the roller
coaster and we're here maybe about to
come to the bottom or to go back up
maybe things are going to change
maybe it it is it's maybe it's not as
bad as it can get the night is always
dug us before the dawn
but watching these media companies fail
to be able to do the oscars oscars are
over
they put out a statement they were like
it's trump's fault for giving everyone
covet
nobody cared the oscars is trash joe
biden
speaks as president nobody cares he's a
trash president
that gives me some optimism i like it
not that i think trump is the is the
savior of the republic or anything
he's better than biden but maybe now we
might actually get something
better in 2024 it's like having not like
ron desantis is perfect either but
he's better than trump it's like we got
a crappy boat captain
and that we put in charge so but at
least people are acknowledging
he's a crappy boat captain but he might
have yeah he might end up
listening to a glacier so we got to keep
that in mind donald trump
was flying a plane and the plane was
kind of bumpy because the whole time
you had other people banging on his door
and rocking everything and then blaming
him for the turbulence
he was like trump was a braggart he was
boastful and he kind of
changed directions quite a bit it's the
best weather the best
the best turbulence it's everybody
listen
there's turbulence it's okay it's good
everybody actually enjoys it
it's kind of nice you know some people
yeah it's the best turbulence
is banging on the cockpit door making it
impossible
it's the best terminal you've ever seen
people people were angry
and in part because of things trump
failed to do yes and
and in part because they were riled up
and raged by the democrats so then they
vote to swap out the pilot with
biden who fell asleep and now the plane
is just
and we're all just like sitting this is
laughing in the co-pilot scene
no she's standing behind it smiling
elbow bumping nancy pelosi
got a pillow i think i think the
propaganda i think the propaganda is so
powerful
through disney through mainstream media
through cnn
through the mainstream music industry
every channel of art that you see i
think i think the propaganda
is so powerful that they are really
convincing people
um that they are the majority that the
radical neo-marxists and the
anarchists and antifa and all the sjws i
think they are
successfully painting the picture in the
minds of millions of people that they
are actually the majority in this
country i don't think they are
yeah i think it's quite the opposite i
think there are a lot of
not just conservatives um centrists
people that are pro-america
pro-patriotism they want to see their
country succeed
uh they want to build their own empire
and wealth in this country they could
really care less about race or any of
these things
i think there are a lot more of us than
there are them and i think the
mainstream media is really painting the
picture successfully
that there's more of them than there are
us so i think more people need to wake
up to that reality and i encourage
people man i was telling lydia this in
the car on the way here too is like
let's be thankful that we are in a place
right now
where all that's happening to us that
disagree and speak out against the
mainstream media or narrative is we get
canceled
let's let's just thank god that's kind
of where it is right now
and we're not getting killed yet over
this because i think that's where we are
going so i encourage people to get
involved listen you may not be the next
tim pool
you may not be the next joe hernandez or
you name it right but
wherever you are specifically in your
life we need more people
that have these pro-america views to get
active in their communities
especially education law order all these
avenues mainstream media all of it
people need to seriously start speaking
up right now might be the next in
crossland
i don't think i don't think ian's evil
tim you'll be the banality of evil
do you think he's evil i think he's an
evil villain but it's it's the banality
of evil
so when people hear the word evil they
think it's
dr evil but the banality of evil is
someone saying well you know
the law says i have to do it so i'm
gonna do it
i'm very much uh i love i'm i'm way more
like uh
chaotic and anarch anarchists kistik
than it seems
you know i have to be kind of level for
for the world for tv
and all that but man i am a
revolutionary at heart
uh i can't stand evil laws i think
they're thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments on
the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time